this is a production of Cornell
University
it's such a pleasure to be speaking to
this bright room
and then I feel so proud of the people
my teachers everyone who have taught me
and they will give me the opportunity to
be here today
right
so
in the early 60s
Nigeria a very interesting country
prior to the discovery of oil
Nigeria had
a lot of food to eat
you are food self-sufficient
and we also had enough to export to the
world
in this period
Nigeria
had over 60 percent of his GDP coming
from Agriculture and about 70 percent of
gainful employment while also in
agriculture
and then 62 percent of our foreign
resale comes from
I mean foreign earnings comes from
agriculture
so dandelion
quite a few things have changed now
and
in this period
people now struggle to find photo hate
and there's a growing unemployment
rates in a country
because we also have a very Rising
population
currently right now and enjoy is not
only the largest country in Africa was
in the top seven globally
we are over 200 million people
and then we have a very youthful
population
with an average age of 18.1
now why am I interested in this sector
a little story back to the 60s
there was a man that was popularly
called babaradio
in a community this man that buried you
he has a job
and his job is to wake up every morning
set up the community radio at a Time
Square
the technology they use at that time he
programs the technology for the radio
frequency to to connect
then they don't only broadcast their
nails on the radio the community radio
they also broadcast Market information
and other advisories around cocoa
Granite Rubber and coffee and palm oil
which were the prominent Nigerian crop
at this time
so many farmers rely on the service of
babaradio
who connects them to the rest of the
country to know the commodity price of
cocoa
to know what's to sell when to sell and
other Market information that is
essential for their
agriculture
practices
now many years down the line but I do
happens to be my grandfather
we'll service Community for many years
and I am so privileged and honored to
also continue in his tradition of also
serving my community
of small agriculture
practitioners some farm for themselves
some for that
also some sell some just want to farm
just for family to make money
so when you look at this map
you see that Nigeria is has a very
unique advantage of being close to the
Antarctic ocean
which also contributed to the Nigerian
economy and Nigeria is a very much
ethnic nation and very diverse
and uh
also
right now the contest of agriculture in
my country is that
we have lost so many gaps from over 70
percent of gain food employment now down
to about 34 percent
not only that we also have
24 now of our GDP from agriculture
and then 80 percent of the farmers in
the country has stayed small that from
us and 68 million people rely on
agriculture as their primary means of
livelihood so these are
very important figures I wanted to bear
in mind as we're going in this slide
so agriculture is not just
for export
it is a means of livelihood for us it is
connected to the culture to the
community and
people see agriculture as a gift
so
I would like to let you have a little
bit more information about some other
farmers because I realized that the
context of small order agriculture is
different from country to Country and
then I also like you to so that we can
be on the same page when I say small
that format and then
it is from my many years of working in
Nigeria with smaller farmers one of the
interesting thing I've learned is that
from Community to community smaller
farmers are highly diverse and very
unique
like I mentioned earlier some at the
subsistence level they just want to farm
just for farming sake likely for
self-consumption
sometimes when they are able to they
sell or give the gift out why some are
small scale commercial small order
farmer very complex classification
but this are interested in consuming
what they produce and they are also
Market oriented when they say Market
opportunity to produce a crop that will
sell they wouldn't mind then we now have
very recently landscape commercials
smaller farmers who are not interested
in farming majorly for the markets
so we classify them sometime also we
also included demographic
characteristics but that is also
changing in the past it used to be the
very old farmers
not very educated but now we have the
mix of this it is common to have Bankers
in Nigeria with in agriculture who are
farms and probably want to sell or want
to eat so that's why they included
demograph
so the common Paradigm of small
agriculture for Africa for Nigeria is
alohi that put
food are insecured what I ask myself
this smaller Farmers they have done an
amazing job taking care of the soil and
also providing some other ecosystem
Services nature-based Services then we
have actually done especially the
industrial culture system
so I said okay what else we considering
a new paradigm whereby if we quantify
the contribution of this agriculture to
water and soil management
to recreations
so keeping our base for pollination and
also contributing to having the kind of
ecological systems whereby we are proud
to live and raise our children
if we quantify this and pay them for
this maybe they are not so low yielding
maybe that actually profitable and how
are you doing and also food has gone
beyond just food for calorie increase
not as a very strong Focus for nutrition
as well and then we sell their resource
for but I say they are resource Limited
because they are rich in other take care
of Nature and their community
they can be unorganized in our sense in
our description but in the real sense
actually Community Driven they rely on
one another they learn from one another
they care for one another you don't need
to invite people in my country in
smaller communities to come to your
wedding or to your birthday celebration
they just show up at their door with big
smiles
so and their system is highly knowledge
intensive
yeah we say they are low literacy rate
but these guys they produce food
without soy science crop science without
genetics and
many other innovations that we have
access to that take a lot of
intelligence and brilliancy for them to
understand themselves all through the
year and their better environmental
stewards
so I also like to show you
quickly that uh why we
consider all of this
and why this conversation is very
important is because
the population of Nigeria and like many
other African countries
is increasing population explosion
and yet our culture productivity is
actually reducing and that is why we are
in this room right now
so the agriculture food system outcomes
that we desire to see in the next couple
of years we want to improve nutrition
and health outcomes we also want to
develop our communities because of
increase in population leading to
urbanization and migration
we want to be able to make more food
healthy food and also reduce
environmental impact of food production
and then we also want to be able to
build this sustainable and resilient
Food Systems
these are some of the dilemas that we
have like how do we achieve all of this
without contributing to environmental
degradation
and also when I think about this and I
look at the trends of Technology
I see that there's going to be a lot of
massive job loss in agriculture sector
most especially the familiar jobs will
be lost for new jobs and the new jobs we
require new level of skills
that probably many people in this region
don't currently have so this also gets
me worried and if we don't
do what we should do if we don't program
and design some of our Innovations and
solutions right we may further increase
social inequality and for that
contribute to
ah poverty
so how do we ensure we do all of this
and protect this our desirable outcomes
against technological innovations and
they also reduce or probably eliminate
or
negative environmental analysis so these
are some of the conversations that we
think about
so for us to achieve our
food system outcomes there are
constraints this constraint they are
still dead if not disappeared
infrastructure Capital impute climate
change is a big one there
sometimes there's a policy fragmentation
or policy disconnection whereby the
policies don't actually address what
they should address sometimes we are not
sure we should subsidize or we shouldn't
subsidize we should be subsidized and
these are some of the issues that we
still have we are familiar with some of
these terms
I just want to highlight that when you
also look at the input space
you in Nigeria currently now the average
fertilizer usage performer it's a little
bit over 300 kilogram
foreign
you can do the mathematics that is very
low I think
in Nigeria today less than 16 percent of
our household actually use a tractor
motorized or equipment on their Farms
most of the farm still takes place with
uh non-motorized equipment or wheat the
colors and Hope
and also only six percent of our Farmers
currently have access to irrigation
facility
so when you build this in mind that we
design crop programs or soy programs or
crop Improvement to Agricultural
Development programs these are some of
the factors that we need to have at the
back of our mind they don't have their
the very elaborate or Advanced
environment for production like uh we
have
so
I mean Manchester United football fan at
any time Man U is not playing
the other thing that keeps me up at
night is these two graphs
and that is because
when you look at Nigerians I've got your
productivity
against Nigeria's population growth
this is worrisome
not only is this warisa
Nigeria has been projected to outgrow
USA population wise by 2050.
so this could be something good
but that also requires a lot more
resources we have a green population to
feed
and right now in Nigeria men's yield a
hexa is six times less than miss you per
hectare in the U.S
and generally in sub-Saharan Africa
Africa has over 15 percent of
area for cultivation of mess globally
but the year that was actually five
percent
so these are very important uh
statistics that I would like you to bear
in mind
and interestingly also we never
understood how vulnerable we were to all
of this until they are very recent
Russia and Ukraine war that our children
have very vulnerable way out to the
current Global Food system
so something needs to be done and this
is my headache I think about this a lot
so in the last couple of uh yes so many
natural development programs have been
designed some were designed focused
around uh
improving adoption of mechanized
agriculture some around increasing
irrigation systems some Miranda
increasing access to genetically
improved seed varieties or
or extension system whereby we train
Farmers improve their capacity knowledge
conservation agriculture these are some
of the initiatives that have been
designed to
improve agriculture productivity in
Nigeria and some other part of Africa
and very recently
now due to agriculture is a new
Innovation on the desk
and it's super exciting what we can do
with digital agriculture
however also willing to be careful so
that digital agriculture will not fail
to achieve what it promises just like
many other previous innovations that we
are
and we need your help to do this because
right in this room these are this is a
collection of some of the finest and the
brightest mind around the world
so if you are aware of these issues it
means you can also contribute to
ensuring that we are able to achieve our
food system our outcomes
so I will talk a little bit about
digital Agriculture and then some of the
work I've been able to do with some
other people in the space and then the
ecosystem of Agriculture the current
gaps and the awards I think we should do
or focus on going forward
so
the beautiful part of digital
agriculture is it gives us the
opportunity
to be able to influence
on the farm level decisions
but this time around not the generalized
prescribed solution but being able to
tailored the solutions or the
recommendations
to the agroclimatic conditions and also
to socio-economic settings of the
locations where we are
and this is so fascinating because like
I said earlier Nigeria has about six
distinct agricological zones
then it's also a very important National
country with different ethnic group over
250 ethnic groups in Nigeria we speak
over 500 languages
so it's very possible for me to meet
three Nigerians that we can't even
communicate in our local languages and
that's why some of us speak our English
so these also play out in agriculture
development
and because of this being able to bring
in some level of precision customization
it's an amazing opportunity for us and
this is why digital Arc is so so
fascinating for me and if we do this
right we'll be able to achieve not only
desirable outcomes but also be able to
change the narratives and in Nigeria at
this time there are about six key
drivers of digital AG innovation in
Nigeria
one of them is a digital uh
technological advancement around the
world Nigerians are very vibrant and
very
uh enterprising people
so
we see the technological development
around the world and we find out ways to
adopt and also customize them to address
our challenges not only that as a very
strong increase in mobile phone
penetration in Nigeria
and also climate change has showed us
that we can't just leave our Farmers to
guesswork anymore we need to also
support them and capacitate that
decision making with data
and Nigerian governments have been also
very supportive with very robust and
very well taught uh policies as well
so let's look at the digital agriculture
ecosystem and then we'll talk about
denim blast and then we look at the
promises and I will show about three
case studies of some of the work we've
done
so digital uh ecosystem in Nigeria are
around the world generally anyway
it relies on their name Plus
the infrastructures and also it could be
adapted to different situations and
different uh challenges or gaps in their
cultural space
so
data is very important this is data
driven without the ability to be able to
share data and connect different data
points it is impossible to be able to do
anything with digital hack
and more importantly
I also would like to emphasize that we
should also not get carried away with
what G2 and culture can do what the
digital Innovations can do also begins
also
look at the enabling environment in
which digital ad needs to operate
without the right policy institutions
especially socio-economic institutions
without the way increasing literacy
importantly digital literacy as well and
the business environment where all of
this takes place it'll be very difficult
for digital act to deliver on these
promises and if we are able to connect
The Right Use cases
with the rights or infrastructure
environments and then with the right
enabling enablers definitely we can
achieve this uh macro impacts and then
across a different uh space we can
improve for security food and nutrition
security index not only that we can also
increase the economic growth
at outside level and nationally and then
we this can contribute big time to
sustainability around the Environmental
resilience also promoting some other
initiative around our environment and
importantly also like a lot of the work
we did Jesus has an opportunity for us
to reduce gender inequality
and also be able to integrate our
marginalized and our forgotten
communities if I have more time I will
share at least one example of how we
apply this
so let's look at uh quickly three use
cases then we can have more time to
discuss
so uh in this case I'll be sharing a
case of a government-led digital AG
program I will share in that case on uh
that was led by development organization
that was part of and also I will share
in that case with of a private agritec
firm who is also piloting some
Innovative solution in the space I'm
involved in these three cases so I know
it deep down and I was fortunate to be
the program laid across
so uh the first case was the this was
funded by ifad that's International fund
Factory development under their program
called the Rapport stimulus facility
project we generally
uh seeks to improve agriculture
productivity in countries around the
world Pakistan India and Nigeria Kenya
Uganda Ethiopia and some other countries
and the specific time of reference for
this particular project was for us to
develop and expand due to ergonomic
extension system in Nigeria and then the
objective was for us to reduce uh the
impact of the covenanting pandemic on
domestic food supply
even though there is a reduction in our
agriculture productivity in Nigeria in
the urban areas over 34 percent of the
food supply still comes from the smaller
the Agriculture and in the rural area up
to 70 percent of their food comes from
their production activity so this is a
very important project and I also like
to mention that uh
extension services in Nigeria and many
other parts of Africa it's not like in
the U.S that the university has so
connected to the extension system and
Farmers have access to extension system
currently in Nigeria less than 25
percent of our Farmers have access to
extension service
and then
in a solid that we conducted over 50
percent of the farmers in the study said
they have never participated in any
uh Farm Level Training experimentation
or party spiritual research or at any
agricultural Workshop so they have to
rely on generational uh learnings
information sharing Farmers to farmers
are learning system
so and right now the extension agent in
the country to Farmers ratio is one
extension agent to about seven thousand
to ten thousand smaller farmers so it's
impossible no one can make anything good
out of that the figure is this one so
this is how very important this is for
us so like I mentioned earlier about the
digital environment that infrastructure
that needs to be in place the enabling
environment for digital app to deliver
skill we were able to
characterize the space and look for the
available infrastructure we could
leverage so we realized that uh mobile
phone penetration is still very low
I mean internet enabled mobile phone
there are assets of phones break and
feature phones but internet enabled
phone is still very low so we developed
a system that is a capacitable with
non-internet enabled phone feature
phones and not only that we also focused
on being able to
communicate with the farmers in their
own languages
so we develop our digital extension
systems and translated all the content
excuse me to local languages excuse me
I'm getting so used to Winter sorry
so
we translated this content or this is
better we translate it content to
the local languages
and we ensure that the system can get
across to the farmers even through their
uh break and feature phones so no need
for internet
however we still have to rely on access
to the telecommunication signals so the
delivery mechanism server was used the
ivr platform for pharmacy calling and
make specific requests and we are able
to get across back to the pharmacy that
true SMS or through a push call that
they receive on their mobile phone just
like a call
and then we had a mandate to focus on
these priority food crops that cut
across both crops for calorie increase
and around nutrition as well and after
different level of iteration we come up
with this priority agronomic topics
Focus around crops the Agronomy of the
crop the soil and the environment in
which the scrubs grows and uh on this
particular project
we were able to we have so many
learnings and then we also make some
recommendations to be able to take this
for that to the next level
I'm pressed for time now so quickly I'll
talk about the second uh case so on this
second case under major challenges
around the access to finance this is one
of the constraints to agriculture
development in my country so we design a
digital phone book a digital Financial
phone book that is able to connect the
agre-preneurs and enterprising Farmers
with agricultural Finance organization
or projects and that they could learn
more about financial products available
in the country or within certain radios
that they could assess and then also
understand the requirements the
eligibility for this financial access
and then they could apply so this
project is still the pilot phase and we
started this late last year we're trying
at this pilot phase to connect with two
thousand agre-preneurs and some other
farmers in the country majorly focusing
with the youth and then farmers who are
focused uh who are interested in taking
the approach to the market so they could
sell and pay back the loan then also
assess a more financial product
and this project
it's important because
Farmers most time has to rely on the
ability for them to either monetize
other assets that is not connected to
agriculture to carry out agricultural
production which is another issue that
we feel like this is one of the reasons
why the poverty index is not improving
because land is an asset so no one
should have to set their land because
they want to produce food for the
country so and recently because of
government policy and government support
financial institutions are beginning to
become interested in their cultural
space so now there's a friction of
connecting the targeted group would have
few available Financial products and
this is why we develop our data
particular projects
so we make use of the ivr and also SMS
platform to get across today we did this
so that we minimize the risk of
eliminating or missing the targeted
group
and this is what the user interface look
like so we make this to be compatible
with non-internet phones so the educated
farmers who can read and write can
easily take out their mobile devices and
they can use the ivr platform to send in
SMS receive message and follow the
prompt because search for financial
products they could learn about the
financial products and see which they
are qualified for and requirements and
then if they have any question more they
also get a contact detail of the desks
or the financial service so this is
still developing and then we haven't
evaluated the impact of this particular
project but I'm super excited and on the
fact that people can be in their
Community where there is probably no
internet and they can learn about
financial products include their fish
farm or the applicable Farm or that
or agricultural production so lastly the
last case is the case with uh yes Mass
yes Mars is a you know better architect
company that is providing precision
tools and resources to connect Farmers
to tailored Farm level adversaries and
all of their services are customized and
tailored to individual users that is the
amazing thing for me about this
particular
uh organization and then they came with
a lot of technology and resources to
support the smaller farmers
and essentially they are learning on as
they move along so initially when they
started they were focusing on Commercial
agriculture but they soon realized that
the the skill for commercial culture is
quite low in Nigeria
you can get more critical mass of
farmers producing food in the small
other farming settings so now the
Dilemma is out to adapt that technology
to suit the smaller farmers and these
they've done since 2020 to recently
they've been able to they customize some
of their solutions to fix the
reality on iguana this time trucks
offline uh
devices or sensors at this time we're
not working Nigeria
because this is a system whereby we have
less than six percent of the farmers
have access to tractor
so the solution that could help could be
simple solution just like these tools I
like to just walk you to some of their
products
for example you could talk about the
feed Pro which is used to map the field
this does not only map the field but it
also provides information with the help
of the Drone with the elevation of the
field and then they could get the ndvi
of the field as well and be able to
advise the farmer and say okay this is
your vegetation Index this is your best
chance on what to plant on this crop I
mean on this uh farmland and
interestingly many farmers don't know
the actual size of their field
because in the traditional Indian
society when we we don't usually sell
land we give us land many years but that
that is changing anyway and I was
sharing with Professor Elizabeth at that
time that sometimes when we want to give
you a Farmland we just ask you we give
you a stone
then we ask you to throw the stone like
a shot put so the fathers your stone can
reach wherever it stops and that is your
farm
yes so many people they Farm on the same
land over many years without knowing the
actual size of the farm so for financial
institutional Financial Services
providers Farm size is very important
because it means that when you know the
actual size of your field then you could
plan your agribusiness activity around
the input size you need the amount of
loan you'll need if you are practicing
an organic system you need fertilizer
the quantity the quantity of seed that
you need to plant on your field and
other information so this way you are
able to eliminate over providing
Financial Resources for a farmer beyond
their current
form a capacity or under providing
resources for them this is the
usefulness of like this product
so they also have a product around soil
Pro which is for is a site testing kit
and then it gets uh for knowing so many
solar elements then they have a smart
site which is a weather advisory product
this particular product in Nigeria it's
not very easy to access so whether
adversary like here in the US see now
I'm still not used to checking my phone
for weather information before leaving
the house so most times I get caught up
without my jacket I'm already out of the
house so it's very it's a it's a it's a
novel product and super useful because
now farmers can be advised over a couple
of weeks to months on the climatic
conditions when there's going to be
rainfall it is going to be a draft spell
and that they can plan their Farm
accordingly I have participated very
funny in a in 2019 I was doing a project
at this time and this particular group
of farmers they planted their crop then
there was a cessation of this of the of
the rainfall there was a dry spell for
about three weeks and this was just
right after seedling and transplanting
of the tomato seedlings so we gather the
community square and we have to pray to
God to give us Ray so it's funny I
participated in the prayer section as
part of solidarity
but I understand that we could have
averted this loss if we have weather
advisory information
so this is why it's important that this
kind of simple digital Arc Innovations
they might not be a big day too here in
the U.S but in the context of our
Farmers to increase their productivity
they are very useful tools
so the application I think for
for you as a soil scientist and crop
specialist could be the big innovations
that we develop for the super big AG
maybe there's a way we could also find a
ways to make this product flexible and
useful for the small different context
and it's important because when you look
at the population coming out of
our country when you look at our age
group
a population of 18 years average
this looks to me like a blessing to the
world in the next couple of years so the
world will rely on youthful population
of Africa to continue to sustain the
planet's Earth so contributing to the
growth and development of young people
in this part of the world is actually
contributing to our good and development
as well this is important
so uh right now I just want to show some
few gaps in digital culture space as I
round up my presentation
and as promising as digital agriculture
is it also comes with some challenges
and these are some of the gaps in the
space
there's going to be massive loss of jobs
agricultural related jobs
so I think about this already and
there's going to be
new jobs will come on but definitely but
these new jobs will require new skill
sets which currently are missing so we
also need to begin to think about this
and in addition to this also I have seen
it play out on the field that due to
agriculture Innovations can contribute
to social exclusion
and how this can happen especially for
women and resource limited farmers
because of the cost of preparing digital
act and also sometimes because of some
other social cultural uh
reasons so we must be aware of this and
for us to be able to successfully
address social inclusion in access to
digital AG this requires
expertise which could also increase
costs of development
so
it's also another issue that many of us
might not be able to answer on the field
that we also need to think about
and we I will come back to this point
so also many of uh due to add
companies
they are still struggling to find a
viable business
model
that can keep the business to be viable
and also scalable that is because of the
price point and also because of the
current uh
economic conditions in the space they
are targeting and if we don't encourage
this space for the innovators to also
look about this space what is going to
happen is innovators for business reason
we focus more on who can pay for the
products and then that will further
increase social inequality
so and uh
I think about this that
most of the time people want to know oh
how many farmers are you working with
oh how many people are you reaching and
that sometimes we focus so much on one
million Farmers 10 million Farmers
assess our Solutions and because of this
this put pressure on us as developing uh
practitioners so sometimes we it's very
easy to sacrifice systematic and
incremental development research
understanding the space and its needs
more in order to be able to
construct a narrative of oh this is
scalable and this is impactful at skill
it's a dilemma that we don't usually
talk about but I think we should talk
about it because those numbers are not
just numbers they're actually humans
so if we are able to do this and it's
useful even if it's a smart group it is
something and that could be a starting
point to make a difference
and uh
public infrastructure is still a very
huge issue
without the right public infrastructure
due to act is very limited and we need
to be able to increase energy access in
our communities in Nigeria today only 45
percent of Nigeria have access to stable
electricity
so it is very common to call
for me to call my family and friends in
Nigeria and they don't have electricity
for hours sometimes for days
so which means that sometimes farmers
can keep their phones charged and then
it's a challenge it which means I they
may not be able to you may not be able
to reach them and decisions on the field
don't wait for us things are happening
environmental factors are playing us
also the many of these some other
communities are disconnected from
markets some houses coming from other Ag
Services so we also need the public
infrastructure to bridge the gaps so
that the two I can deliver on this uh
promises
so if we want to go and make a change
and be able to transform our food system
we should think about these numbers and
this information I've shared this
afternoon
and then we must also think about the
enablas the right policies the social
Economic Institutions that needs to
support not only that also
infrastructure not only that research
and development and I want to emphasize
the point on research and development
that this time around this has to be
transdisciplinary
these guys know a lot I have learned so
much from some other farmers
so if it is transdisciplinary we are by
farmers are not recipients of a solution
by participants in both the development
in the design development and
deployments
I think this is going to make a lot of
difference because it musically
contributes their knowledge some of them
they have knowledge of about 10 000
years they've been passed on to them
if they are able to contribute this
probably some of these products will be
so much better than what we currently
have
and my argument is not that we should
stop developing digital Technologies for
excuse me for the industrial agriculture
system
but I'm saying that we should also
think about the smaller Farmers because
this is a critical mass of people
and there's something that we do in my
culture
not only is it significant for us to
dress like this when we are very happy
but also there's a very strong element
of addressing and this is the cup
whether it's something that people don't
know about this cup that makes this cup
very special
depending on how you put on this cup it
sells different message
when I wear this cup this way
and
and I style it this way on my dressing
for people who understand the fashion
design
and the science behind this car
it means that I am an eligible bachelor
I'm probably looking for a sort of
because of the way to start to the right
side
but this same cap is flexible enough
amenable that when I bend it to this
side
and I style it this way
it means I am of the market
are not eligible
so this flexibility about this car
makes it so beautiful
and useful in diverse settings
this can also be digital Act
d2r can be for the big farmers for this
medium farmers and even for the small
farmers if we do this correctly if we
make it flexible if we make it adaptable
for wide range of farmers then trust me
we can achieve a full system
transformation at result but we can do
this without you because our best link
you do research you understand some of
these topics that we do we need this
transpinary collaborations
soy
crop digital AG innovators the farmers
themselves as partners not as recipients
then with this we can achieve this so I
think uh I'll stop here then we can take
questions and also those discuss thank
you so much for having me
thank you very much John
um do we have questions in the room yes
have you seen
anything like the way that small forward
or Farmers manage fast changing what
kind of proliferation of Technology like
maybe you've got a scouting or
communicate to their neighbors like hey
this is how many Pebbles here or
anything like that
thank you very much good question but
yes
the
communities already built Iran strain of
everything
they shed around they share the water
the chef would they share their job and
their sadness
so also they share information
so whenever something new comes on board
once one Farmers know that they're very
unlikely that every performance
connected remotely directly to that same
commands to be aware of this
and this is one of the
courses that we have used very well to
our advantage
so we also initiate uh things like a
master performance training foreign
[Music]
for decision making
um and developing a database so I was
wondering what decisions of it was
supposed to to support and what goes in
the database
and a related question is how are these
Air smart people going to make money I
guess you you alluded to that but I
first I was curious what what we're
going to do with the soil database thank
you so much good question
so one other thing they're trying to do
is do it in a solid database collect
Insight samples
and analyzing these are samples the
elements of the saw what makes it so
unique and distinct
this area thank you
so what that is going to do for them is
going to enable them to be able to
provide
me every time I dress for services so if
somebody brings in a soy sample that
fits the cases of that stuff
[Music]
that is one
is
high technology whereby they are
planting feed sensors in different Farms
collecting this soil data as well so
it's also meant to do the same to be
able to build a soil profile for the
country it's a very huge project and
I hope that they'll be able to sustain
this so the decision making then is just
fertility Management in that case yes
okay big time yes I I spoke to one of
their users a a small scale commercial
farmers who subscribe for this
particular product and he told me that
what this does for them is it's useful
for them in managing no trends
so now they know they can when they are
planning their
farming season they know the quantity of
nutrient fertilizer they should be
buying so that way they could save money
instead of buying and then they could
apply different properly they use that
that for them to make money the current
model now is they are currently working
with a financial institution a bank a
commercial bank that is providing ad
Finance or
facility for the farmers so they
participate in this connected projects
using the feed Pro to first map the farm
and be able to do yield projection
so that way you know how much Financial
go to the farmer so that they're doing
cure debt that they can pay then
secondly how much input it's required
for the production to
to go through yes it's still difficult
for them because it means I
only who can
um sorry
so I
I was a nice question but I wonder if
there's a way to
[Music]
um
this technology without transforming
farming into something you know from
something that is very low cost you know
low input activity
it doesn't require Taco fuel that
um change the environment
to prevent that kind of change in
something that involves high high cost
this is one of the thank you so much for
that contribution not a question it's
not the future
if we are able to do this correctly it
means that performance can say okay
I don't know organic matter here this is
Rich I don't need to apply any
fertilizer here
maybe I need it somewhere else but not
scary they could say oh one of these
services that this particular ad company
provider so to be able to advise
looking at the soil profile and say this
is the appropriate crop for this
sometimes Farmers plant a crop because
some other farmers are planting actually
based on the soil that you are you
should be planting rice and not mixed
these are some of the usefulness of the
sort of idea
all right thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu